The following is a conversation with
Eric Weinstein. He's a mathematician,
economist, physicist, and the
managing director of Teal capital.
He coined the term and you can say is
the founder of the intellectual dark web,
which is a loosely assembled
group of public intellectuals.
That includes Sam Harris, Jordan and
Pearson, Steven Pinker, Joe Rogan,
Michael Shermer,
and a few others.
This conversation is part of
the artificial intelligence
podcasts at MIT and
beyond. If you enjoy it,
subscribe on Youtube, iTunes,
or simply connect with me on Twitter
at [inaudible] Friedman, spelled f,
r I.
D.
And now here's my conversation
with Eric Weinstein.
Are you nervous about this? Scared
shitless. Okay. The busboy, Chris. Yeah.
You mentioned Kung Fu panda is
one of your favorite movies.
It has the usual profile master
student dynamic going on.
So who was,
who has been a teacher that's significant
influence the direction of your
thinking in life's work? So if you're
the Kung Fu panda, who was your she fu?
Oh,
well it's interesting because I didn't
see she as being the teacher who was the
teacher. Oui. Master. Obey
the turtle. All the turtle,
right?
They only meet twice and the
tire film and the first
conversation sort of doesn't count.
So the magic of the film,
in fact, it's point yeah.
Is that the teaching that really
matters is transferred during a single
conversation. Right. And it's very brief.
And so who played that role in
my life, I would say, uh, either,
uh, my grandfather, uh,
Harry Reuben and his wife Sophie Reuben,
my grandmother or Tom Lehrer top layer.
Yeah.
In which way if you give a
child Tom Lehrer records,
what you do is you destroy their ability
to be taken over by later malware.
And it's so irreverent,
so witty, so clever,
so obscene that it destroys the ability
to lead a normal life for many people.
So if I meet somebody who usually
really shifted from any kind
of neurotypical presentation,
I'll often ask them,
uh,
are you a Tom Lehrer fan?
And the odds that they will
respond or are quite high. Now,
Tom Layer is a poisoning pigeons in the
park Tom Layer. That's very interesting.
There are a small number of Tom Lehrer
songs that broke into the general
population poisoning pigeons in the park.
The element song and
perhaps the Vatican reg. Uh,
so when you meet somebody who knows
those songs but doesn't know how you're
judging me right now, aren't you
harshly? Uh, no, but you're Russian.
So I got as a you known Nico
Evanovich a Chesky. That's us. Yeah.
So that was a song about plagiarism
that was in fact plagiarized,
which most people don't know
from Danny Kaye. Uh, we're,
Danny Kaye did a song called
Stanislavski of the Musky Arts.
And so Tom Lehrer did this brilliant job
of plagiarizing a song about and making
it about plagiarism and then making it
about this mathematician who worked in
non EUCLIDEAN geometry.
That was like a giving heroin to a child.
It was extremely addictive and eventually
led me to a lot of different places,
one of which may have
been a phd in mathematics.
And he was also at least the lecture
in mathematics, I believe at Harvard.
Something like that. Yeah, I just
had dinner with him. In fact,
when my son turned 13, we
didn't tell him, but, um,
his bar Mitzvah present
was dinner with his hero,
Tom Lehrer and a toddler was 88 years old,
sharp as a tack,
irreverent and funny as
hell. And just, you know,
there are very few people in this world
that you have to meet while they're
still here. And that was
definitely one for our family.
So that wit is a reflection
of intelligence in some kind of deep way.
Like where that would be a
good test of intelligence,
whether you're a Lehrer fan.
So what do you think that is about?
What about that kind of humor,
ability to see the absurdity in existence?
What do you think that's connected to
intelligence or we just to Jews on a mic
that appreciate that kind of humor?
No,
I think that it's absolutely
connected to intelligence. So you can,
you can see it.
There's a place where Tom Lehrer
decides that he's going to lampoon, uh,
Gilbert of Gilbert and Sullivan and
he's going to outdo Gilbert with clever,
meaningless wordplay. And he
has, I forget the honesty. He,
he's doing clementine as if Gilbert and
Sullivan wrote it and he says that I
missed her depressed. Her young
sister named Mr this, Mr Pessler,
she tried pestering sisters,
a festering blister.
You best to resist or say I the sister
persisted. The Mr existed. I kissed her,
all loyalty slipped when he said,
when she said, I could have her,
her sister's cadaver must surely have
turned in a script that's so dense.
It's so insane that that's
clearly intelligence,
uh, because it's hard to
construct something like that.
If I look at my favorite Tom Lear,
Tom Lehrer lyric,
you know,
there's a perfectly absurd one,
which is once all the Germans
were warlike and mean,
but that couldn't happen again.
We taught them a lesson
in 1918 and they've hardly
bothered us since then. Right?
That is a different kind of intelligence.
You know,
you're taking something that
is so horrific and you're,
you're sort of making it palatable
and funny and demonstrating also,
um, just your humanity. I mean, I
think the thing that came through as,
as Tom Lehrer wrote all of these terrible,
horrible lines was just what a sensitive
and beautiful soul he was who was
channeling pain through
humor and through grace
I've seen throughout Europe,
throughout Russia that same kind of
humor emerge from the generation of World
War Two.
It seemed like that humor is required
to somehow deal with the pain and the
suffering of that that war created.
Well,
you do need the environment to
create the broad Slavic soul.
I don't think that many
Americans really appreciate,
um,
Russian humor.
How you had to joke during the time
of let's say article 58 under Stalin,
you had to be very, very
careful. You know, the,
the concept of a Russian
satirical magazine like
crocodile a doesn't make sense.
So you have this cross cultural problem
that there are certain areas of human
experience that it would be
better to know nothing about.
And quite unfortunately, eastern
Europe knows a great deal about them,
which makes the,
you know,
the songs of letting me or Wysocki's
so potent the, uh, you know,
the pros of Pushkin, whatever it is, uh,
you have to appreciate the depth of
the Eastern European experience. And I,
I would think that perhaps Americans knew
something like this around the time of
the civil war or maybe, um, you know,
under slavery and Jim Crow or even the,
uh,
harsh tyranny of a,
the coal and steel employers
during the Labor wars. Um,
but in general,
I would say it's hard for us to understand
and imagine the collective culture
unless we have the system of
selective pressures. For example, uh,
Russians were subjected to,
yeah. So if there is one good
thing and that comes out of a war,
it's literature,
art and a humor and music.
Oh,
I don't think so.
I think almost everything is good about
war except for death and destruction,
right? Eh, without the
death they would bring, uh,
and the romance of it. The whole thing
is nice. This is why we're always
caught up in war and we have this
very ambiguous relationship to it,
is that it makes life real
and pressing and meaningful
and at an unacceptable price.
And the price has never been higher.
So jumping
into AI a little bit,
you,
uh,
in one of the conversation you had or
one of the videos you described that one
of the things AI systems can't
do and biological systems,
can his self replicate in the
physical world? No, no, no.
In the physical world, well, yes,
the physical robots can't self replicate,
but if it,
but this is a very tricky point,
which is that the only thing that
we've been able to create that's really
complex that has an analog
of our reproductive system
is software.
But nevertheless,
software rep replicates itself.
If we're speaking strictly for the
replication in this kind of digital space.
So let me just to begin,
let me ask a question.
Do you see a protective barrier or a
gap between the physical world and the
digital world?
What's that?
Call it digital,
let's call it the logical world
versus the physical world.
Why logical? Well, because
even though we had, let's say,
Einstein's brain preserved,
uh,
it was meaningless to us as a physical
object because we couldn't do anything
with what was stored in
it at a logical level.
And so the idea that something may be
stored logically and that it may be stored
physically, uh, are not necessarily a,
we don't always benefit
from synonymous there.
I'm not suggesting that there isn't a
material basis to the logical world,
but that it does warrant a identification
with the separate layer that need not
invoke logic gates and Zeros and ones.
And,
uh,
so connecting those two worlds of the
logical world and the physical world or
maybe just connecting to the
logical world inside of our brain.
[inaudible] brain.
You mentioned the idea of out
intelligence, artificial intelligence,
artificial intelligence. Yes.
This is the only essay that John
Brockman ever invited me to write that he
refused to publish an edge.
Why? Well, maybe it wasn't, it wasn't
well written. Um, but I don't know.
The idea is quite compelling is
quite unique and new and for,
at least from my view of Stan's
point, maybe you can explain it. Sure.
What I was thinking about is why it is
that we're waiting to be terrified by
artificial general intelligence,
when in fact, artificial life,
uh, is terrifying in and of
itself. And it's already here.
So in order to have a system
of selective pressures,
you need three distinct elements.
You need variation within a population.
You need heritability and you
need differential success. Okay.
So what's really unique, and I've
made this point, I think elsewhere
about it, software, is that if you think
about what humans know how to build,
that's impressive.
So I always take a car and I say,
does it have an analog of each of
the physical physiological systems?
Does it have a skeletal structure?
That's its frame.
Does it have a n a neurological structure?
It has an onboard computer,
has a digestive system.
The one thing it doesn't have
as a reproductive system,
but if you can call spawn
on a process, effectively, you
do have a reproductive system.
And that means that you can
create something with variation,
heritability,
and differential success.
Now the next step in the
chain of thinking was,
where do we see inanimate
non-intelligent life?
Outwitting intelligent life.
And um,
I have two favorite systems and I try
to stay on them so that we don't get
distracted. One of which is
the Oh, freeze orchid, um,
subspecies or sub clade, I don't know
what to call it as a type of flower. Yeah.
It's a type of flower that mimics the
female of a pollinator species in order to
dupe the males into, uh, engaging.
It was called pseudo copulation
with the fake female,
which is usually represented
by the lowest pedal.
And there's also a fair amount component
to fool the males and to thinking they
have a mating opportunity, but the
flower doesn't have to give up energy,
energy in the form of nectar as a
lower because it's tricking the males.
The other system is a particular species,
uh,
of muscle lamp bacillus in
the clear streams of Missouri.
And it fools bass into biting a
fleshy lip that contain its young.
And when the bass see this fleshy lip,
which it looks exactly like a species of
fish that the best like to eat the, uh,
the young explode and clamp onto
the gills and parasitize the bass.
And also lose the best to redistribute
them as they eventually release both of
these systems.
You have a highly intelligent
duped being fooled by a lower life form.
And what is sculpting these,
these convincing Lewers,
it's the intelligence of previously
duped targets for these strategies.
So when the target is smart
enough to avoid the strategy, uh,
those weaker mimics a fall off.
They have terminal lines and
only the better ones survive.
So it's an arms race between
the target species, uh,
that is being parasitized
getting smarter and this other less
intelligent or not intelligent object
getting as if smarter.
And so what you see is,
is that artificial intelligence,
artificial general intelligence
is not needed to parasitize us.
It's simply sufficient for
us to outwit ourselves.
So you could have a, a program, let's say,
you know, one of these Nigerian scams, um,
that writes letters and uses
whoever sends it Bitcoin,
uh, to figure out which aspects
of the program should be kept,
which should be varied and thrown away.
And you don't need it to be in any way
intelligent in order to have a really
nightmare scenario of being parasitized
by something that has no idea what it's
doing. So you, you, you phrase it,
if you guys have really eloquently,
so let me try it to uh,
as a few
directions. This goes. So one, four s
first on the way we write software today,
it's not common that we allow it to self
modify what we do have that ability.
Now we have the ability, it's just
not common, isn't as common. So,
so your,
your thought is that that is a serious
worry if there becomes a modifying code
is, is available now. So there's different
types of self modification, right?
There's a personalization.
You know, your email app,
your Gmail is a self modifying to
you after you log in or whatever.
You can think of it that way.
But ultimately it's central.
All the information is centralized,
but you're thinking of ideas
where you're completely,
so this isn't a unique entity,
uh,
operating under selective pressures
and it changes. Well, you just,
if you think about the fact that our
immune systems don't know what's coming at
them next, but they have a small
set of spanning components,
and if it's,
if it's a sufficiently expressive
system in that any shape,
uh, or binding region can
be approximated, uh, with,
with the Lego that is present.
Um,
then you can have confidence that you
don't need to know what's coming at you
because the common,
a torics
are sufficient to reach any
configuration needed. Uh,
so that's a beautiful thing.
Well,
terrifying thing to worry about
because it's so within our reach,
whatever I suggest these things,
I do always have a concern as to whether
or not I will bring them into being by
talking about them. So, uh, there's
this thing from open AI, so,
uh, next next week. So talk
to fonder of Openai, uh,
this idea that a, their text
generation, the new, uh,
the new stuff they have for generating
texts is they didn't want to bring it,
they didn't want to release it
because they're worried about the god.
Delighted to hear that, but they're
going to end up releasing. Yes.
So that's the thing is I think talking
about it. Um, well at least from my end,
I'm more a proponent of
Technology preventing techno,
uh,
so further innovation,
preventing the detrimental effects
of innovation. What were the,
were sort of tumbling down a
hill at accelerating speed.
So whether or not we're proponents or it
doesn't really mean it may not matter,
but I do not. Well, I do feel that there
are people who've held things back and,
uh, you know, died poor than
they might have otherwise been.
We don't even know their names.
I don't think that we should discount
the idea that having the smartest people
showing off how smart they are by what
they've developed. Maybe a terminal
process. I'm, I'm very
mindful in particular,
have a beautiful letter that Edward
Teller of all people wrote to Leo Szilard
and whereas Szilard was trying to
figure how to control the use of atomic
weaponry at the end of World War II and
teller rather strangely because many of
us view him as a monster,
um,
showed some very advanced moral thinking,
talking about the slim
chance we have for survival.
And that the only hope is
to make Warren thinkable.
I do think that not enough of us feel in
our gut what it is we are playing with.
When we were working
on technical problems,
and I would recommend to
anyone who hasn't seen it,
a movie called the bridge over the
bridge on the river Kwai about I believe
captured British POW [inaudible] who just
in a desire to do a bridge well end up
over collaborating with
their Japanese cap.
Well now you're making me a question.
The under strict it open
discussion of ideas and AI.
I'm not saying I know the answer,
I'm just saying that I could make a
decent case for either our need to talk
about this and to become technologically
focused on containing it or need to
stop talking about this and try to hope
that the relatively small number of
highly adept individuals who are looking
at these problems is small enough that
we should in fact be talking
about how to contain them.
Well,
the way ideas,
the way innovation happens when new
ideas develop a Newton with calculus,
whether if, ah, he was
silent, the idea would be,
would emerge elsewhere in case Casey
Newton of course. But, uh, you know,
it went in case of AI,
how small is the set of individuals
out of which such ideas would arise
is it isn't one of the,
the ideas that the researchers we know
and those that we don't know who may live
in countries that don't wish us to know
what level they're currently at and very
disciplined and keeping these, uh,
things to themselves. Of course,
I will point out that there is a
religious school in Kerala that developed
something very close to the calculus,
certainly in terms of infinite series in,
um,
I guess religious prayer, uh, and, and uh,
and Ryman pros. So, you know,
it's not that Newton had any ability
to hold that back and I don't really
believe that we have an
ability to hold it back.
I do think that we could change the
proportion of the time we spend worrying
about the effects of what if we are
successful rather than simply trying to
succeed and hope that we'll be
able to contain things later.
Beautifully put.
So on the idea of intelligence,
what form trading cautiously is we've
agreed as we tumbled down the hill,
uh, what happens is the upper cells, can
we, we can, we cannot, uh, well formed.
Do you, do you see it taking?
So one example, Facebook,
Google of it. We'll do one too.
I don't know a better word.
You want to influence users
to behave a certain way.
And so that's one kind of example of
our intelligence is a systems perhaps
modifying the behavior of their,
the,
these intelligent human beings in order
to sell more product of different kinds.
But do you see other examples of this
actually emerging in just take any
parasitic system?
You know,
make sure that there's some way in
which that there's differential success
heritability
and in variation and those
are the magic ingredients.
And if you really wanted to
build a nightmare machine,
makes sure that the system that
expresses the variability, uh,
has a spanning set so that it
can learn to arbitrary levels,
uh, by making it sufficiently
expressive. That's your nightmare.
So it's your nightmare.
But it could also be as,
it's a really powerful mechanism by
which to create well powerful systems.
So are you more worried about the negative
direction that might go versus the
positive?
So you say parasitic,
but that doesn't necessarily need to
be what the system converges towards.
It could be a, what is
it? They are a citizen.
The dividing line between
parasitism and symbiosis
is not so clear. That's what they tell
me about marriage. I'm still single,
so I know. Well, um, yeah, I,
we can go into that too, but no,
I think we have to
appreciate, you know, are,
are you infected by your own Mitochondria?
Right,
right.
Yeah.
So, you know, in marriage you
fear the loss of independence.
But even though the American,
uh,
therapeutic community may be very
concerned about codependence,
what's to say that codependence isn't
what's necessary to have a stable
relationship in which to raise children
who are maximally case selected and
require incredible amounts of care
because you have to wait 13 years before
there's any reproductive payout.
And most of us don't want our 13 year
olds having kids as a very tricky
situation to analyze.
I would say that, um,
predators and parasites drive much of
our evolution and I don't know whether to
be angry at them or thank them.
Well,
ultimately the,
I mean nobody knows the meaning of
life or what even happinesses, but uh,
there is some metrics, but did she
tell you they, they didn't. Uh,
that's why all the poetry and
books are about the, you know,
there is some metrics under which you
can kind of measure how good it is that
these AI systems are roaming about.
So you're more,
you're more nervous about software,
then you are optimistic about
ideas of self replicating.
I don't think we've really
felt where we are.
You know,
occasionally we get a wake up
nine 11 was so anomalous
compared to everything we've up,
everything else we've experienced on
American soil that it came to us as a
complete shock that that
was even a possibility.
What it really was was a highly creative
and determined r and d team deep in the
bowels of Afghanistan.
Um,
showing us that we had certain exploits
that were open to that nobody had chosen
to express.
I can think of several of these things
that I don't talk about publicly that
just seem to have to do with,
um,
how relatively unimaginative those who
wished to cause havoc and destruction had
been up until now.
The great mystery of our time,
of,
of this particular little era is how
remarkably stable we've been since 1945
when we demonstrated the ability
to use a nuclear weapons in anger.
And we don't know why things like
that haven't happened since then.
We've had several close calls. We've
had mistakes, we've had a brinksmanship.
And what's now happened is that
we've settled into a sense that,
oh, it's, it'll always be nothing.
It's been so long since something was
at that level of danger that we've got a
wrong idea in our head. And that's why
when I went into the Ben Shapiro show,
I talked about the need to resume
above ground testing of nuclear devices
because we have people whose developmental
experience suggests that when,
let's say Donald Trump and North
Korea engage on Twitter, oh,
it's nothing. It's just
posturing. Everybody's just in
it for money. There's there,
there's a sense that people
are in a video game mode,
which has been the right call since 1945
we've been mostly in video game mode.
It's amazing.
So you're worried about a generation
which is not seeing any existential,
we've lived under it. You see your
younger, I don't know if if, uh,
again you came from, from
Moscow. Yeah. There was a,
a TV show called the day after
that had a huge effect, uh,
on a generation,
uh,
growing up in the U s and it talked
about what life would be like after a
nuclear exchange.
We have not gone through
an embodied experience
collectively where we've thought
about this.
And I think it's one of the
most irresponsible things
that the elders among us
have done,
which is to provide this beautiful
garden in which the thorns are cut off of
the,
of the rose bushes and all of
the edges are rounded and sanded.
And so people have developed this,
this totally unreal idea,
which is everything's
going to be just fine.
And do I think that my leading concern
is Agi or my leading concern is a
thermonuclear exchange or gene drives or
any one of these things? I don't know.
But I know that our time here in this
very long experiment here is finite
because the toys that we've built are so
impressive and the wisdom to accompany
them has not materialized.
And I think we actually got
a wisdom uptick since 1945
we had a lot of dangerous
skilled players on the world stage.
Nevertheless,
no matter how bad they were
managed to not embroil us
in something that we couldn't come back
from the Cold War and the distance from
the Cold War.
You know,
I'm very mindful of,
uh,
there was a Russian tradition actually
of on your wedding day going to visit a,
a memorial to those who gave their
lives. Can you imagine this, where you,
you are the happiest day of your life.
You go and you pay homage to the people
who fought and died in the battle of
Stalingrad.
Um,
I'm not a huge fan of communism,
I gotta say,
but there were a couple of things
that the Russians did that were really
positive and the Soviet era.
And I think trying to let people know
how serious life actually is, is a,
is the Russian model of seriousness
is better than the American model.
And maybe like you mentioned,
there was a small echo of that
after nine 11, but we would,
we wouldn't let it form.
We talk about nine 11,
but it's nine 12 that really move the
needle when we were all just there and
nobody wanted to speak.
We some,
we witnessed something super
serious and we didn't want to, uh,
run to
our computers and blast out our
deep thoughts and our feelings.
And it was profound because we
woke up briefly there. You know,
I talk about the gated institutional
narrative and that sort of programs our
lives,
I've seen it break three times in my life.
One of which was the
election of Donald Trump.
Another time was the fall of Lehman
brothers when everybody who knew that bear
Stearns wasn't that important,
knew that Lehman brothers
met AIG was next.
And the other one was nine 11.
And so if I'm 53 years old,
and I only remember three times that the,
the global narrative
was really interrupted.
That tells you how much we've
been on top of developing events.
You know, I mean, we had the Moreau
felt federal building explosion,
but it didn't cause the narrative
to break wasn't profound enough.
Around nine 12,
we started to wake up out of our slumber
and the powers that be did not want to
coming together. They, you know, the, the,
the admonition was go shopping and uh,
the powers that be was, what does that
force as opposed to blaming individually,
we don't know. So whatever
that, whatever that force is,
there's a component of it that's emergent
and there's a component of it that's
deliberate. So give yourself a
portfolio with two components.
Some amount of it is emergent,
but some amount of it is
also an understanding that
if people come together,
they become an incredible force.
And what you're seeing right now I think
is there are forces that are trying to
come together and there are forces
that are trying to push things apart.
And you know,
one of them is the globalist narrative
versus the national narrative where to
the global, a globalist perspective, uh,
the Nash nations are bad things
in essence that they're temporary,
they're nationalistic,
they're jingoistic.
It's all negative to people in the
national, more in the national idiom,
they're saying, look, this
is where I pay my taxes.
This is where I do my army service.
This is where I have a vote.
This is where I have a passport.
Who the hell are you to tell me that?
Because you've moved into someplace
that you can make money globally,
that you've chosen to abandon other
people to whom you have a special and
elevated duty.
And I think that these
competing narratives have been
pushing towards the global
perspective,
uh,
from the elite and a larger and larger
number of disenfranchised people are
saying, Hey, I actually live in a,
in a place and I have laws and I
speak a language. I have a culture.
And who are you to tell me that?
Because you can profit in some far away
land that my obligations to my fellow
country, men are so, so much diminished.
So these tensions in
between nations and so on,
ultimately you see being proud
of your country and so on,
which creates potentially the kind
of things that led to wars and so on.
They ultimately, it is human nature and
it is good for us, uh, for wake up calls,
a different kinds of, oh, I think that
these are tensions. And my point isn't,
I mean,
nationalism,
run a muck is a nightmare
and internationalism run
a muck is a nightmare.
And the problem is we're
trying to push these pendulums,
uh, to some place where
they're somewhat balanced,
where we have a higher duty of
care to those who share our log,
our laws and our citizenship.
But we don't forget our duties
of care to the global system.
I would think this is elementary,
but the problem that we're facing concerns
the ability for some to profit the
event by abandoning their obligations
to others within their system.
And that's what we've had for decades.
He mentioned nuclear weapons.
I was hoping to get answers from you since
one of the many things you've done as
a economics.
It may be you can understand human
behavior of why the heck we haven't, uh,
blowing each other up yet, but, okay.
So, uh, we'll get it. I know the answer.
And you said it's a fast,
it's really important to say
that we really don't know.
MILDEP up ticking wisdom, a mild uptake
and wisdom. That's was Steven pig.
Bingo is who I've talked with has a
lot of really good ideas about why.
But nobody,
I don't trust his optimism.
Listen, I'm rushing, so I never trust the
guy. Was that optimists? No, no, no, no.
You're talking about a guy who's looking
at a system in which more and more of
the kinetic energy, like war has
been turned into potential energy,
like unused nuclear weapon.
Beautifully put. And you know,
now I'm looking at that
system and I'm saying, okay,
well if you don't have a potential energy
term than everything's just getting
better and better. Yeah. Wow. That's as
beautifully put. Only physicists. Got It.
Okay. Uh, not a physicist.
Is that a dirty word?
No, no. I wish I were a physicist.
A me too. My Dad's a physicist.
I'm trying to live up that
probably for the rest of my life.
He's probably going to listen
to this too. So he did. Yeah.
So your friend Sam Harris, uh, worries a
lot about the existential threat of Ai,
not in the way that you've described,
but in the more well,
he hangs out with Ilan.
I don't know.
So are you worried about
that kind of, uh, you know,
about the,
um,
about either robotic systems or,
you know,
traditionally defined AI
systems essentially becoming
a superintelligent much
more intelligent than human beings and,
uh,
getting what they already
are and they're not, when,
when seen as, um, a collective
you mean? Well, I mean,
I can mean all sorts of
things, but certainly many
of the things that we thought
were peculiar to general intelligence
or do not require general intelligence.
So that's been one of
the big awakenings that
you can write a pretty convincing sports
story from stats alone without needing
to have watched the game. So, you know,
is it possible to write lively pros
about politics? Yeah, no, not yet.
So we were sort of all over the map. One
of the, one of the things about chest,
you'll,
there's a question I once asked on
Quora that didn't get a lot of response,
which was what is the greatest brilliancy
ever produced by a computer and a
chess game,
which was different than the question of
what is the greatest game ever played.
So if you think about resiliencies is
what really animates many of us to think
of chest as an art form,
those are those moves and combinations
that just show such flare pinash and, and,
and, and soul. Um, computers
weren't really great at that.
They were great positional monsters.
And
you know,
recently we,
we've started seeing brilliancy and so
you're grand masters have identified with
that with Alpha zero that things were
quite brilliant. Yeah. So that's great.
That's it. That's it. You know,
that's an example of something
we don't think that that's Agi,
but in a very restricted set,
a set of rules like chess,
you're starting to see
poetry of a high order and,
and so I'm not, I don't like the
idea that we're waiting for Agi.
Agi is sort of slowly infiltrating our
lives in the same way that I don't think
a worm should be.
You know,
the sea elegans shouldn't be treated
as nonconscious because it only has 300
neurons and maybe just has a very low
level of consciousness because we don't
understand what these things
mean as they scale up.
So am I worried about this
general phenomena? Sure.
But I think that one of the things
that's happening is that a lot of us are
fretting about this, uh, in
part because of human needs.
We've always been worried
about the Gollum, right?
Well, the gums, the artificially created
life, you know, it's like Frankenstein.
Yeah, sure. It's a Jewish version
and um,
Frankenberg Frankenstein.
That's makes sense. All right, so the, uh,
but we've always been worried about
creating something like this and it's
getting closer and closer
and there are ways in which
we have to realize that the whole thing
has come up with a whole thing that
we've experienced are the context of our
lives is almost certainly coming to an
end. And I don't mean to suggest that, uh,
we won't survive.
I don't know.
And I don't mean to suggest that it's
coming tomorrow and it could be 300,
500 years,
but there's no plan that I'm aware of.
If we have three rocks that we
could possibly inhabit that are
sensible within current
technological dreams, the earth,
the moon and Mars,
and we have a very competitive
civilization that is
still forced into violence
to sort out disputes that
cannot be arbitrated.
It is not clear to me that we have a
longterm future until we get to the next
stage,
which is to figure out whether or not the
Einsteinian speed limit can be broken.
And that requires our source code,
our source code, the stuff in
our brains to figure out what,
what do you mean by our source code?
The source code of the context,
whatever it is that produces the
corks, the electrons, the Neutrino I,
our source code. I got it.
So this is like, like you're
talking to your best stuff
that's written in a higher level
language. Yeah. If his right,
you're talking about the
low level, uh, the bits,
that's what is currently keeping us here.
We can't even imagine,
you know,
we have harebrained schemes for staying
within the Einsteinian speed limit. Uh,
you know,
maybe if we could just drug ourselves
and go into a suspended state or we could
have multiple generations,
I think all that stuff is pretty silly.
But I think it's also pretty silly to
imagine that our wisdom is going to
increase to the point that we
can have the toys we have and uh,
we're not going to use them for 500 years.
Speaking of Einstein,
I had a profound break that
when I realized you're just
one letter away from the
guy, but I'm also one letter
away from Feinstein. It's,
well, you get to pick. Okay.
So unified theory, you know,
you've worked a, you, you
enjoy the beauty of geometry.
I don't actually know if you enjoy it.
You certainly are quite
good at is Trumbull before
tremble before it is that if
you are religious, that is one of
the good, I have to be religious.
It's just so beautiful. You
will tremble anyway. I mean,
I just read to Einstein's
biography and one of the ways,
one of the things you've done is tried
to explore a, a unified theory, uh,
talking about a 14 dimensional opposite
verse that has the four d space time
continuum embedded in it.
I just curious how you think and how it
philosophically at a high level about
something more than four
dimensions. Uh, how do you try to,
what does it make you feel
talking in the mathematical world about
dimensions that are greater than the
ones we can perceive is,
is there something that you take away
that's more than just the math? Well,
first of all,
stick out your tongue at me.
Okay. Now on the front of that time, yeah,
there was a sweet receptor
and next to that we're salt
receptors and two different sides.
A little bit farther back,
there were sour receptors and you wouldn't
show me the back of your tongue where
you're bitter receptor was show
the good side always. Okay.
But that was four dimensions
of taste receptors.
But you also had pain receptors on the
tongue and probably heat receptors on
that time. So let's assume that you had
one of each, that would be six dimensions.
So when you eat something, you eat
a slice of pizza and it's got some,
some uh, some hot pepper
on it, maybe some Jalapeno,
you're having a six
dimensional experience. Dude,
do you think we overemphasize the value
of time as one of the dimensions or
space?
What we certainly over emphasize the value
of time cause we like things to start
and end or we really don't like
things to end, but they seem to, well,
what if you flipped one of the spatial
into being a temporal dimension
and you and I were to meet
in New York City and say,
well were where and when
should we meet and say,
how about I'll meet you on 36th and
Lexington at two in the afternoon and uh,
11 o'clock in the morning.
That would be very confusing.
Well, so it's a convenient for us to
think about Tommy, you mean? All right.
We happened to be in a delicious situation
in which we have three dimensions of
space and one of time and they're woven
together in this sort of strange fabric
where we can trade off a
little space for a little time,
but we still only have one dimension
that is picked out relative to the other
three.
It's very much Gladys knight and the pips,
so which one developed for who do we
develop for these dimensions or did the
dimensions or were they
always there and it doesn't?
Well,
do you imagine that there isn't a place
where there are four temporal dimensions
or two and to have space and time or three
of time in one of space and then with
time not be playing the role of space.
Why do you imagine that the sector
that you're in is all that there is?
I certainly do not,
but I can't imagine otherwise.
I mean I haven't done Iowasca or any,
any of those drugs that hope to one day,
but so doing Iowasca you could
just head over to building too.
That's where the mathematicians
are. Yeah. That's where they hang.
Just to look at some geometry. We'll just
ask about pseudo Romani and geometry.
That's what you're interested in.
Okay.
Or You can talk to a Sharma and then
ended up in Peru and then it's an extra
money for that.
You won't be able to do any calculations
if that's how you choose to go about it.
Well, a different kind of calculation so
to speak. Yeah. One of my favorite people,
Edward Frankl, Berkeley professor, author
of love and math, great title for a book,
uh,
said uh,
that your quite a remarkable intellect
to come up with such beautiful original
ideas
in terms of the unified theory and so on,
but you are working outside academia.
So one question in developing
ideas that truly original,
truly interesting.
What's the difference between
inside academia and outside
academia when it comes
to developing such a terrible choice?
Terrible choice.
So if you do it inside of academics,
you are forced to constantly
show great loyalty to the consensus and
you distinguish yourself with small,
almost microscopic heresies, uh,
to make your reputation in general.
And you have very competent people and
brilliant people who are working together
who are
form very deep social networks and
have a very high level of behavior,
at least within mathematics and at
least technically within physics,
theoretical physics.
When you go outside you beat
lunatics and crazy people
madmen.
And these are people who do not usually
subscribe to the consensus position and
almost always lose their way.
And the key question is,
will progress likely come from someone
who is miraculously managed to stay
within the system and is able to take on
a larger amount of heresy that is sort
of unthinkable, uh, in which
case that will be fascinating.
Or is it more likely that somebody will
maintain a level of discipline from
outside of academics and be able to make
use of the freedom that comes from not
having to constantly affirm your
loyalty to the consensus of your field?
So you've characterized
in ways that I could,
academia in this particular
sense is a declining,
you are posted a plot.
The older population of the
faculty's getting larger,
the younger is getting smaller and so on.
So what's,
which direction of the two are
you more hopeful about? Well,
the baby boomers can't hang on forever.
Was it first of all in general, true.
And second of all in academia.
But that's really what I think what
this time is about is the baby boomers.
We didn't,
we're,
we're used to like financial bubbles
that lasts a few years in length and then
pop the baby boomer bubble is this
really long lived thing and all of the
ideology, all of the behavior
patterns, the norms, you know,
for example, string theory is and
almost entirely baby boomer phenomenon.
It was something that baby boomers were
able to do because it required a very
high level of mathematical ability.
You don't, you don't think of a
strength theory as a, an original idea.
Oh, I mean it was original to Veneziano
would probably is older than the baby
boomers and there are people
who are younger than the
baby boomers who are still
doing string theory.
And I'm not saying that nothing discovered
within the large string theoretic
complex is wrong.
Quite the contrary.
A lot of brilliant mathematics and a
lot of the structure of physics was
elucidated by string theorists.
What do I think of the deliverable
nature of this product that will not ship
called string theory?
I think that it is largely an
affirmative action program for highly
mathematically and geometrically talented
baby boomer physics physicists so that
they can say that they're working on
something within the constraints of what
they will say is quantum gravity. Now
there are other schemes, you know,
there's like ask them Todrick safety.
There are other things that
you could imagine doing.
I don't think much of any
of the major programs,
but to have inflicted this level of
loyalty through a Shibboleth.
Well,
surely you don't question y question
almost everything in the string program,
and that's why I got out of physics
when you called me a physicist.
It was a great honor,
but the reason I didn't become a
physicist wasn't that I fell in love with
mathematics. As I said.
Wow. In 1984, 1983,
I saw the field going mad
and I saw that mathematics,
which has all sorts of problems,
was not going insane.
And so instead of studying
things within physics,
I thought it was much safer to study
the same objects within mathematics.
And there's a huge price to pay for that.
You lose physical intuition.
But the point is, is that it wasn't a
North Korean reeducation camp either.
Are you hopeful about cracking open the
Einstein unified theory in a way that
has been really, really, uh,
understanding whether a uniting everything
together with content Tyrian so on.
I mean I'm trying to play this role
myself to do it well if you the extent of
handing it over to the more responsible,
more professional,
more competent community.
Um,
so I think that they're wrong about a
great number of their belief structures,
but I do believe,
I mean I have a really profound love hate
relationship with this group of people.
I think the physics side,
Oh yeah.
Because the mathematician is actually
seem to be much more open minded and uh,
well they are and there aren't,
they're open minded but anything that
looks like great math, right? Right.
They'll study something that
isn't very important physics,
but if it's beautiful
mathematics then they'll have uh,
they have great intuition about these
things. As good as the mathematicians are.
And I might even intellectually at some
horsepower level, give them the edge.
The theoretics theoretical
physics community is bar none.
The most profound intellectual
community that we have ever created.
It is the number one, there is nobody
in second place as far as I concerned,
look in their spare time and the spare
time they invented molecular biology.
What, what was the origin of
molecular biology? You're saying Phil?
Somebody like Francis Crick.
I mean a lot,
a lot of the early molecular
biologists or physicists. Yeah, I mean,
you know, Schrodinger wrote what is
life and that was highly inspirational.
I mean you have to appreciate that
there is no community like the basic
research community in theoretical physics.
And it's not something I'm
highly critical of these guys.
I think that they would just wasted,
you know,
decades of time with,
um,
and your religious devotion
to their misconceptions,
realization of where the
problems were in physics.
But this has been the
greatest intellectual
collapse ever witnessed within
academics.
You see it as a collapse or just a little,
oh, I'm terrified that we're
about to lose the vitality.
We can't afford to pay these people.
Um,
we can't afford to give
them an accelerator just to
play with in case they find
something at the next energy level.
These people created our economy.
They gave us the Rad lab and radar.
They gave us two atomic
devices to end World War II.
They created the semiconductor and the
transistor to power our economy through
Moore's law. Uh, as a positive
externality of particle accelerators.
They created the worldwide web.
And we have the insolence to say,
why should we fund you with our tax
payer dollars? No. The question is,
are you enjoying your
physics dollars? Right? We,
these guys signed the world's
worst licensing agreement. Right?
And if,
if they simply charged for every time
you used a transistor or a URL a or
enjoyed the piece that they have
provided, um, during this period of time,
through the terrible weapons
that they developed, uh,
or your communications devices,
all of the things that power our economy,
I really think came out of physics.
Even to the extent the chemistry came
out of physics and molecular biology came
out of physics.
So first of all,
you have to know that I'm very critical
of this community. Second of all,
it is our most important community.
We have neglected it, we've abused it,
we don't take it seriously.
We don't even care to get them to rehab
after a couple of generations of failure,
right?
No one,
I think the youngest person to have really
contributed to the standard model of
theater medical level was
born in 1951 right? Frank,
we'll check and almost
nothing has happened, um,
that in theoretical physics after 1973
74 that sent somebody to Stockholm
for theoretical development,
that predicted experiment.
So we have to understand that we are doing
this to ourselves. Now with that said,
these guys have behaved
abysmally in my opinion, um,
because they haven't owned up
to where they actually are,
what problems they're really facing,
how definite they can actually be.
They haven't shared some of their
most brilliant discoveries which are
desperately needed in other
fields like gauge theory,
which at least the
mathematicians can can share,
which is an upgrade of the differential
calculus of Newton in live nuts and they
haven't shared the importance
of renormalization theory. Uh,
even though this should be standard
operating procedure for people across the
sciences, dealing with different layers
and different levels of phenomenon.
So shared,
you mean communicated in such a way
that a dis disseminates throughout the
different of these guys are sitting,
both theoretical physicists
and mathematicians are
sitting on top of a giant
stockpile of intellectual gold,
right?
They have so many things that have not
been manifested anywhere. I was just on
Twitter,
I think I mentioned the Habermann switch
pitch that shows the self duality of
the tetrahedron realized
as a linkage mechanism. No,
this is like a triviality and
it makes an amazing toy that's,
you know, built a market. Hopefully
a fortune for chuck Hoberman. Well,
you have no idea how much great stuff that
these priests have in their monastery.
So it's truly a love and hate
relationship for you. Well,
it sounds like it's more on the love this
building that we're in right here. Yes.
Uh,
is the building in which I really put
together the conspiracy between the
National Academy of Sciences and the
National Science Foundation through the
government university industry research
round table to destroy the bargaining
power of American academics,
uh,
using foreign labor with a on
microfiche and not in the base. Oh yeah.
That was done here in this building.
Isn't that weird?
And I'm truly speaking with
a revolutionary and radical
a, I don't know. No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
At an intellectual level, yes,
I am absolutely garden variety.
I'm just straight down the middle.
The system that we are in this,
this university is functionally insane.
Yeah.
Harvard is functionally insane and we
don't understand that when we get these
things wrong,
the financial crisis made this very clear.
There was a long period where every
grown up, everybody with a tie, uh,
who spoken in bear
baritone tones, uh, with,
with the right degree, uh, at
the end of their name. Yeah. Uh,
talking about how we banish volunteer
volatility, we're in the great moderation.
Okay. They were all crazy.
And who was, who was right?
It was like Nassim Taleb Nouriel Roubini.
Now what happens is,
is that they claimed the market went, went
crazy, but the market didn't go crazy.
The market had been crazy.
And what happened is, is
that it suddenly went sane.
Well,
that's where we are with academics.
Academics right now is mad as a
hatter and it's absolutely evident.
I can show you graph after graph.
I can show you the internal discussions.
I can show you the conspiracies.
Harvard's dealing with one right now
over a its admissions policies for people
of Color, uh, who happened
to come from Asia.
All of this madness is necessary
to keep the game going.
What we're talking about, just while
we're on the topic of revolutionaries,
as we're talking about the danger
of an outbreak of sanity, yeah.
You're,
you're the guy pointing out the elephant
in the room here and the elephant has
no clothes.
Is that how that goes?
I was going to talk a
little bit to, uh, uh,
Joe Rogan about this man at a time,
but I think you're,
you have some,
you can just listen to you.
You could probably speak really
eloquently to academia on the differences
between the different fields.
So you think there's a difference between
science and engineering and then the
humanities in academia in
terms of tolerance that
they're willing to tolerate.
So from my perspective,
I thought
computer science and maybe engineering
is more tolerant to radical ideas,
but that's perhaps innocent of
me is that I always, you know,
all the battles going on now or a
little bit more on the humanity side and
gender studies and so on.
Have you seen the, uh,
American Mathematical Society
is publication of an essay
called get out the way?
I have not.
What's,
what's the idea is that white men who
hold positions within universities and
mathematics should vacate their position
so that young black women can take over
something like this.
That's in terms of diversity,
which I also want to ask you about.
But in terms of diversity
of strictly ideas, I'm sure.
Do you think,
cause you're basically saying physics
as a community has become a little bit
intolerant to some degree to new
radical ideas or at least you,
uh, you said that's changed
a little bit recently,
which is that even string theory
is now admitting, okay, we don't,
this doesn't look very promising
in the short term. Right?
So the question is what compiles,
if you want to take the
computer science metaphor,
what will get you into a journal?
Will you spend your life trying to push
some paper into a journal or will it be
accepted easily? What do we know about
the characteristics of the submitter
and what gets taken up and what does not?
All of these fields are experiencing
pressure because no field is performing so
brilliantly? Well, um,
that it's revolutionizing
our way of speaking and thinking in the
ways in which we've become accustomed.
But don't you think even
in theoretical physics,
a lot of times, even with theories,
extinct theory, you could speak to this.
It does eventually too. What are the
ways that this theory would be testable?
And so ultimately,
although look,
there's this thing about popper and the
scientific method that's a cancer and a
disease in the minds of very smart people.
That's not really how most
of the stuff gets worked out.
It's how it gets checked, right? So,
and there is a dialogue
between theory and experiment,
but everybody should read.
Paul Directs 1963 American
scientific American article where he,
he, you know, it's very interesting,
he talks about it as if it was about the
Schrodinger equation and Schrodinger's
failure to advances on work because
of his failure to account for some
phenomenon. And the key point is that
if your theory is a slight bit off,
it won't agree with experiment,
but it doesn't mean that the
theory is actually wrong.
But direct could as easily have been
talking about his own equation in which he
predicted that the electrons
should have an anti.
And since the only positively charged
particle that was known at the time was
the Proton Heisenberg pointed out, well
it shouldn't, you're anti particle,
the Proton have the same
mass as the electronic.
Doesn't that invalidate your theory?
So I think the direct was actually being
quite potentially quite sneaky. Um,
and uh,
talking about the fact that he had been
pushed off of his own theory to some
extent by Heisenberg. Um, but look,
we fetishize the scientific method
and popper and falsification,
um, because it protects us from
crazy ideas entering the field. So,
you know,
it's a question of balancing type one
and type two error and we're pretty,
we were pretty maxed out in one
direction. The opposite of that. The,
let me say what comforts me sort
of biology or engineering, uh,
at the end of the day does the thing work?
Yeah.
You can not test the crazies
away. The crazy eight. We'll see.
Now you're saying,
but some ideas actually crazy and
some are are actually correct. So,
well there's pre correct. Currently
crazy. Yeah. Right. And so you,
you don't want to get rid of
everybody who's pre correct.
And currently crazy. Um,
the problem is,
is that we don't have standards in general
for trying to determine who has to be
put to the sword in terms of their
career and who has to be protected, uh,
as some sort of giant time suck pain in
the ass, uh, who may change everything.
Do you think that's possible? Uh,
creating a mechanism of those select well,
you're not going to like the
answer, but here it comes. Boy,
it has to do with very human elements.
We're trying to do this at the
level of like rules and fairness.
It's not going to work because the only
thing that really understands this,
you're read the read the
double helix. It's a book. Oh,
you have to read this book.
Not only did Jim Watson,
uh ha half discover this
three dimensional structure.
DNA is also one hell of a writer
before he became an ass that no,
he, yeah, he's tried to destroy his own
reputation and you bought the asset.
Didn't know about the good writer.
Jim Watson is one of the most
important people now living. And, uh,
as I've said before,
Jim Watson is too important a
legacy to be left to Jim Watson. Um,
that book tells you more about
what actually moves the dial.
And there's another story about him,
which I don't, I don't agree with,
which is that he stole everything
from Rosalind Franklin. I mean, the,
the problems that he had with
Rosalind Franklin are real,
but we should actually honor that
tension in our history by delving into it
rather than having a simple solution.
Jim Watson talks about Francis
Crick being a pain in the ass,
that everybody is secretly knew it was
super brilliant and there's an encounter
between a charge f,
uh,
who came up with the equimolar relations
between the nucleotides who should have
gotten the structure of
DNA and Watson and Crick.
And you know,
he's talks about missing a shiver
in the heartbeat of biology.
And this stuff is so gorgeous and just
makes you tremble even thinking about it.
Um,
look,
we know very often who is to be feared
and we need to fund the people that we
fear.
The people who are wasting our time need
to be excluded from the conversation
you see. And you know, maybe we'll
make some errors in both directions,
but we have known our own people.
We know the pains in the
asses that might work out.
And we know that people who are really
just blow hards are really have very
little to contribute. Most
of the time. It's not 100%,
but you're not going to
get there with rules.
Right? It's a using some kind of
instinct. I mean, I, to be honest,
I'm going to make you roll
your eyes for a second. But uh,
and the first time I heard that there is
a large community of people who believe
the earth is flat.
Okay.
Actually made me pause and
ask myself the question,
why would there be such a community?
Yeah. Is it possible the earth is flat?
So I had to like, wait a minute. I mean,
then you go through a thinking process
that I think is really healthy. Uh,
it ultimately ends up being a geometry
thing. I think. Uh, it's an interesting,
it's an interesting thought
experiment at the very least.
Well I do a different version of it. I
say, why is this community stable? Yeah,
that's a good a way to analyze it.
What interesting that whatever we've
done has not erased the community.
So you know, they're taking a long
shot bet that won't pan out. You know,
maybe we just haven't thought enough about
the rationality of the square root of
two and somebody's brilliant,
we'll figure it out.
Maybe we will eventually land one day on
the surface of Jupiter and explore it.
Right. These are crazy
things that will never happen
so much as social media
operates by Ai Algorithms.
He's talked about this a little bit,
uh, recommending the content you see.
So on this idea of radical thought,
how much should AI show you things you
disagree with on Twitter and so on,
in, in a Twitter war verse in the
departments in this quest? Yeah. Yeah.
Cause you don't know the answer.
No, no, no, no. Look, we've been,
they've pushed out this cognitive Lego
to us that will just lead to madness.
It's good to be challenged with things
that you disagree with. The answer is no.
It's good to be challenged
with interesting things
with which you currently
disagree.
But that might be true.
So I don't really care about whether or
not I disagree with something or don't
disagree.
I need to know why that particular
disagreeable thing is being pushed out.
Is it because it's likely to be true?
Is it because, is there some reason?
Because I can write, I can
write a computer generator, uh,
to come up with an infinite number of
disagreeable statements that nobody needs
to look. So please, before you push
things at me that w or disagreeable,
tell me why there is an aspect in
which that question is, is quite dumb,
especially because it's being
used to, uh, almost, um,
uh, very generically by these
different networks to say, well,
we're trying to work this out.
But you know, basically, uh,
how much do you see the value
of seeing things you don't like,
not you disagree with because very
difficult to know exactly what you
articulated,
which is the stuff that's important for
you to consider that you disagree with
it.
That's really hard to figure out.
The bottom line is this
stuff you don't like.
If you are a Hillary Clinton supporter,
you may not want to,
it might not make you feel good to
see anything about Donald Trump.
That's the only thing algorithms
can really optimize for currently.
It really nothing they can do better.
This is where we're, we're thinking.
So now we're engaged in some more ronic
back and forth where I have no idea why
people who are capable of building
Google, Facebook, Twitter,
or having us in these incredibly
low level discussions,
do they not know any smart people?
Do they not have the phone numbers of
people who can elevate these discussions?
They do. But this awesome
idea for a different thing.
And they're pushing those people
out of those rumors there.
They're optimizing for things we
can't see. And yes, profit is there.
No. But it, nobody's questioning that.
But they're also optimizing for things
like political control or the fact that
they're doing business in Pakistan and
so they don't want to talk about all the
things that they're going to be
bending to in Pakistan. So we're,
we're involved in a fake discussion.
You think so you think these
conversations at that depth,
they're happening inside Google.
You don't think they have some basic
metrics under user engagements.
You're having a fake
conversation with us guys.
We know you're having a fake conversation.
I do not wish to be part
of your fake conversation.
You know how to cool these units.
You know, high availability,
like nobody's business.
My Gmail never goes down almost.
So you think just because they can do
incredible work on the software side with
infrastructure,
they can also deal with some of these
difficult questions about human behavior,
human understanding. You're
not, I mean I've seen the,
I've seen the developer's screens that
people take shots of inside of Google.
Yeah. And I've heard stories inside
of Facebook and apple. We're not,
we're engaged. They're engaging
us in the wrong conversations.
We're not at this low level.
Here's one of my favorite questions.
Why is every piece of hardware
that I purchased in, in,
in tech space equipped as a listening,
we're,
where's my physical
shutter to cover my lens?
We had this in the 1970s it cameras
that had blends caps, you know,
how much would it cost to have a
security model pay five extra bucks.
Why is my indicator light software
controlled? Why when my camera is on,
do I not see that the light is on by
putting it as a something that cannot be
bypassed,
why have you set up my,
all of my devices at some difficulty to
yourselves as listening devices and we
don't even talk about this,
this, this, this, this thing
is total fucking bullshit.
Well, I, these discussions
are happening about privacy.
This is there a dif more difficult than
you'd give them. It's not just privacy,
it's about social control.
We're talking about social control.
Why do I not have controls
over my own levers?
Just have a really cute
UI where I can switch.
I can dial things where I can at
least see what the algorithms are.
You think that there is some
deliberate choices being made?
Here is emergence and
there is a intention.
There's two dimensions. The vector
does not collapse onto either access,
but the idea that anybody who suggests
that intention is completely absent is a
child that's really
beautifully put and uh,
like many things you've said is
going to make me, can I trust,
can I turn this around slightly?
Yeah.
I sit down with you and you say that
you're obsessed with my feet. [inaudible]
I didn't even know what my feed is.
What are you seeing that I'm not,
I was obsessive Lee,
looking through your feed a on Twitter
because it was really enjoyable because
it was the Tom Layer element.
Does the humor in it. By the way,
that feed is Eric r Weinstein on
Twitter at Greg. Eric r Weinstein.
It. No, seriously. Why?
Why did I find it enjoyable or
what it was I seeing? What are you,
what are you looking for? Why are we
doing this? What does this podcast about?
I know you've got all
these interesting people.
I'm just some guy who is sort of
a podcast guest sort of access.
You're not even wearing a tie. I mean,
not even wearing I on a serious interview,
uh,
searching for meaning for happiness,
for a dopamine rush.
So short term and long term. And how are
you finding your way to me? What it, what,
what, what is I, I don't honestly
know what I'm doing to reach you.
The representing ideas,
which are feel common sense to me
and not many people are speaking.
So it's Kinda like the dog, the
intellectual dark web folks, right?
Uh,
they s these folks from Sam Harris,
the Jordan Peterson to yourself
are saying things where it's like,
you're like saying, look, there's an
elephant and he's not wearing any clothes.
And I say, yeah, yeah. Well let's
have more of that conversation.
That's how I'm finding you.
I'm desperate to try to,
the conversation we're having, I'm very
worried. We've got an election in 2020.
I don't think we can afford four more
years of a misinterpreted message.
Um,
which is what Donald Trump was.
And I don't want the
destruction of our institutions.
They all seem hell bent
on destroying themselves.
So I'm trying to save theoretical physics.
Trying to save the New York Times is
trying to save are various processes.
And I think it feels
delusional to me that, uh,
cause this is falling to a tiny group
of people who are willing to speak out
without getting so freaked out
that everything they say it will be
misinterpreted and that their lives will
be ruined through the process. I mean,
I think we're in an absolutely bananas
period of time and I don't believe it
should fall to such a tiny number of,
of shoulders to shoulder this weight.
So
I have to ask you on a capitalism side,
you mentioned that technology's killing
capitalism. It has effects that are
unintended, well, not unintended, but, uh,
not what economists would predict
or speak of capitalism creating. Uh,
I just want to talk to
you about in general,
the effect of even then artificial
intelligence or technology automation,
taking away jobs in these kinds of
things in what you think is the way to
alleviate that,
whether the Andrew Ang presidential
candidate with universal basic income ubi.
What are your thoughts there?
How do we fight off the negative
effects of technology? That all right.
Software Guy, right? Yup.
A human being is a worker is an old idea.
Yes.
Human being has a worker is a
different object, right? Yeah.
So if you think about object
oriented programming is a paradigm.
A human being has a worker
and a human being has a soul.
We're talking about the fact
that for a period of time,
the worker that a human being has yeah.
Was in a position to feed the
soul that a human being has.
However, we have two separate
claims on the value in society.
One is as a worker and the other is as
a soul and the soul needs sustenance.
It needs dignity. It needs
meaning. It needs purpose. Okay.
As long as you're means of
support is not highly repetitive.
I think you have a while to go
before you need to start worrying.
But if what you do is highly repetitive
and it's not terribly generative,
you weren't in the cross hairs of
four for loops and while loops,
and that's what computers
excel at repetitive behavior.
And when I say repetitive,
I mean meat.
I may mean things that have never
happened be through common tutorial
possibilities. But as long as it
has a looped characteristic to it,
you're in trouble.
We are seeing a massive push towards
socialism because capitalists are slow to
address the fact that a worker
may not be able to make claims.
A relatively undistinguished median member
of our society is still has needs to
reproduce,
needs to ha to dignity.
And when capitalism abandons the
median individual or you know,
the, the bottom 10th or
whatever it, it's going to do,
it's flirting with revolution.
And what concerns me is
that the capitalists aren't
sufficiently capitalistic to
understand this.
You really want to court a authoritarian
control in our society because you
can't see that people may not be able
to defend themselves in the marketplace
because the marginal product of their
labor w two s to low to feed their dignity
as a soul.
So it,
my great concern is that our free society
has to do with the fact that we are
self organized.
I remember looking down from my office
in Manhattan when Lehman Brothers
collapsed and thinking,
who's going to tell all these people that
they need to show up at work when they
don't have a financial system to
incentivize them to show up at work.
So my complaint is first of all,
not with the Socialists
but with the capitalists,
which is you guys are being idiots.
You're courting revolution by continuing
to harp on the same old ideas that
well, you know, try, try harder.
Bootstrap yourself. Yeah,
to an extent that works to an extent,
but we are clearly headed in place that
there's nothing that ties together our
need to contribute and
our need to consume.
And that may not be provided by capitalism
because it may have been a temporary
phenomena.
So check out my article on anthropic
capitalism and the new gimmick economy.
Uh,
I think people are late getting the wake
up call and we would be doing a better
job saving capitalism from itself.
Um,
because I don't want this done
under authoritarian control.
And the more we insist that,
uh,
everybody who's not thriving in our
society during their reproductive years in
order to have a family is failing
at a personal level. I mean,
what a disgusting thing that we're saying.
What a, what a horrible message. Who To,
who the hell have we become that we've
so bought into the Chicago model, um,
that we can't see the humanity that we're
destroying in that process. And it's,
I hate, I hate the thought
of communism. I really do.
My family has flirted with it
decades past. It's a wrong, bad idea,
but we are going to need to figure out
how to make sure that those souls are
nourished, nourished, and respected
and capitalism better have an answer.
And I'm betting on capitalism,
but I gotta tell you,
I'm pretty disappointed with my team.
So you're still on the capitalism team.
Just a, there's a theme here. Restful,
radical capitalism. Capitalism.
Yeah.
I want,
I think hyper capitalism is going to have
to be cup coupled to hyper socialism.
You need to allow the most productive
people to create wonders and you've got to
stop bogging them down with all of
these extra nice requirements, you know,
nicest dead good. Has a future. Nice.
Doesn't have a future because nice
ends up with, with Goulet eggs.
Damn, that's a good line. Okay,
last question. You a tweeted today,
a simple,
quite insightful equation saying
a imagine that every unit f,
uh, fame you picked up
as stalkers and h haters.
So I imagine acid h are dependent
on your path to fame, perhaps.
Well,
it's not as simple and people always
take these things literally when you have
like 280 characters to explain yourself
as emia there. That's not a
mathematical, uh, no, there's
no law. Oh, okay. All right.
I just said,
why I put the word imagine,
because I haven't slept
with mathematicians.
Desire for precision. Yeah.
Imagine that this were true,
but it was a beautiful way to imagine
that there is a law that has those
variables in it. And uh, you've
become quite famous these days.
So how do you yourself optimize that
equation with the peculiar kind of fame
that you have gathered along the way?
I want to be kinder. I want to be kinder
to myself. I want to be kinder to others.
I want to be able to have heart
compassionate. These things
are really important. And
uh, I have a pretty spectrum.
He kind of approach to analysis.
I'm quite literal.
I can go full rain man on you at any
given moment. No. I can, yeah. Can, uh,
it's faculty to have autism if you like.
And people are gonna get angry because
they want autism to be respected. But yes,
when you see me coding or you
see me doing mathematics, I am,
you know, I speak with speech apnea
me right down to dinner, you know?
Yeah. We have to try to integrate
ourselves. And those tensions between,
you know, it's sort of back to the
US as a worker and us as a soul.
Many of us are optimizing one to the,
at the expense of the other.
And I struggle with social media and
I struggle with people making threats
against, uh, our families.
And I struggle with, um,
just how much pain people are in.
And if there's one message I
would like to push out there, um,
irresponsible. Everybody,
all of us, myself included,
with struggling struggle,
struggle mightily because you,
it's nobody else's job to do your
struggle for you. Now with that said,
if you're struggling and you're trying
and you're trying to figure out how to
better yourself and where you failed and
where you've let down and your family,
your friends,
your worker is all this kind of stuff,
give yourself a break. You know,
if, if, if it's not working out,
I have a lifelong relationship
with failure and success.
There's been no period of my life.
We're both haven't been present
in one form or another. And I,
I do wish to say that a lot of times
people think this is glamorous.
I'm about to go do a show with Sam Harris.
People are going to listen in on
two guys having a conversation on.
It's completely crazy when I'm always
trying to figure out how to make sure that
those people get maximum value. And, uh,
and that's why I'm doing this podcast.
You know, just give yourself
a break. You owe us,
you owe us your struggle.
You don't owe your family or your
coworkers or your lovers or your family
members' success. Um, as long as you're
in there and you're picking yourself up,
recognize that this,
this new situation with the economy that
doesn't have the juice to sustain our
institutions has caused the people
who have risen to the top of those
institutions to get
quite brutal and cruel.
Everybody's lying at the moment.
Nobody's really a truth teller. Um,
try to keep your humanity about you.
Try to recognize that if you're failing,
if things aren't where you want them
to be and you're struggling and you're
trying to figure out what you're
doing wrong, which you could do,
it's not necessarily all your fault.
We are in a global situation.
I have not met the people who are
honest, kind, good, successful.
Nobody that I've met is chick
is checking all the boxes. Uh,
nobody's getting all tens.
So I just think that's
an important message that
doesn't get pushed out enough.
Either. People want to hold society
responsible for their failures,
which is not reasonable. You have
to struggle. You have to try, uh,
or they want to say you're 100%
responsible for your failures,
which is total nonsense.
Beautifully put. Eric,
thanks so much for talking today.
Thanks for having me, buddy.